[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings a hockey
player speaking out publicly for the
first time about being a victim of an
alleged sexual assault kyle beach has
been known as john doe in a lawsuit
filed against the chicago blackhawks he
said a coach assaulted him in 2010 and
he says the team didn't properly
investigate it or report it the
blackhawks finally launched his own
investigation over the summer two
executives have stepped down and the
team has been fined two million dollars
by the league we'll be speaking with
kyle in just a moment he first spoke to
a canadian sports network tsn warning
beach's allegations are disturbing nikki
batiste reports
for kyle beach playing in the nhl in
2010 was a lifelong dream beach alleged
chicago blackhawks video coach brad
aldrich threatened him with a baseball
bat before forcibly kissing and
performing oral sex on him saying he
would never play in the nhl if anyone
found out a 107 page report released
tuesday reveals beach reported the
assault to the team and concludes team
executives ignored his pleas for help
the report says in a meeting about the
allegation executives including former
blackhawks head coach joel quenville
made comments about the challenge of
getting to the stanley cup finals and a
desire to focus on the team and the
playoffs in july quenville who now
coaches the florida panthers denied
hearing the specific allegations
aldrich met with h.r a week after the
team won the title and was told he could
either be placed on leave during an
investigation or resign he resigned but
was paid severance and still
participated in some of the team's
championship celebrations the team never
conducted an investigation in the wake
of tuesday's report we reached out to
aldrich for comment but did not get a
response he told investigators the
encounter with beech was consensual
asked about the report by the associated
press he responded i have nothing to say
in a statement the chicago blackhawks
new management commended beach's courage
in coming forward and apologize for what
he has gone through and for the
organization's failure to promptly
respond when he bravely brought this
matter to light in 2010 it was
inexcusable for then executives of the
blackhawks organization to delay taking
action regarding the reported sexual
misconduct according to the report
aldrich went on to assault a team intern
before he was allowed to resign he held
several other hockey jobs over the next
four years with usa hockey in college
and in high school he pleaded guilty in
2013 to criminal sexual conduct with a
16 year old hockey player in michigan
while volunteering at a high school
there that player is now suing the
blackhawks for cbs mornings i'm nikki
batiste in new york